[Music]
[Music]
yay
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
this one
[Music]
[Music]
ladies
[Music]
ways
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i'll show you today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
three
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
celebrations
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
easy
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
stay in your business
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
never ever
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
thank
[Music]
he's
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen our great vice
president is just moments away from
taking the stage
please find your way to an fdc thank you
is
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
american guy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
as we can see
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
is
is
[Music]
pretty much
[Music]
she's
[Music]
my feet
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you're important
[Music]
[Music]
me
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
founder and ceo of tear tactical
jason beck
[Music]
hey everyone really appreciate everyone
being here
um it's a it's a great honor to uh host
vice president
uh you know this uh this company has
gone a very long way
in a very short period of time you know
we've been around for 10 years kind of
overnight success i guess
right you know we've been in this
industry for 20 years
we've been in the city of peoria arizona
for 20 years
you know we're very very proud we're
very proud family
uh to uh to have
everything that we do now as a nation
and the choices that we make
we firmly believe that the direction
that our country is going
that this administration is trying to do
the right things for us to
stay on course
[Applause]
try to get used to the bright lights
back there
it's very important for us to to all
really think
and consider how the choices that we're
making right now in this country
um you know we're growing further and
further
away from god every choice that we make
and it's extremely important for us to
to really get this country back on
course to really get people to try to
show the enthusiasm
uh you know to show our support for law
enforcement
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know we clearly packed the blue
right
you know we have we have the great
greatest law enforcement
in in any nation i've traveled i've
traveled most of them
you know we do we do body armor for
countries all over
all over this earth and everybody and
everybody
it does not matter what law enforcement
agency it is in a foreign country
always follows the us principles so
so if it tells you anything you know our
nation's
place has to be put back on the right
course you have to stay in the same
course that this administration is
trying to put us on
um you know this vice president that
you're getting ready to listen to
and this president are all focused on
how we're trying to
[Music]
[Applause]
pride with each other there's nothing
wrong with having
the pride in that flag
[Applause]
she should be proud to hold that up you
should be proud proud to be an american
and you should be proud of every law and
be able to shake the hand of any law
enforcement
officer that you see all right
[Applause]
this administration has made great
changes for from the standpoint
of you know tax cuts uh
everything from from the ability for us
to grow as a company
to be able to be able to utilize those
tax cuts to see the building that
everybody passed
that they saw building up front you know
we because of these tax cuts in this
administration we've been able to add
125 jobs
another 80 jobs over the next 12 months
just because of the tax cuts that are
actually taking place
right
and i say this all the time but the
return on investment
on what the administration has done for
this
company it is going to be huge yeah
we've been able to hire this last over
the last 12 months to 24 months
we've hired 78 uh refugees from all
across
all across the
you know we want to continue to do that
and continue to continue to put more
jobs in the city of europe
all right so you know with that i'm not
the best speaker to be up here in front
of these lights
you know we're all here to see the man
right so you know
i would please have you all stand up
welcome vice president pence
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
second lady of the united states
[Applause]
mrs
[Music]
yes
[Music]
so great to be here with you all today
well i get the job of introducing the
vice president today
and so i'm going to tell you a little
story about
our history of getting involved in
politics you can have a seat if you want
because i know when he comes out you're
going to stand and cheer and all that so
when when mike and i were dating when we
were dating
which was about 37 years ago
he told me that he wanted to run for
congress
stay in the far future and so
after we got married he went and asked
the county chairman
what should i do if i want to run for
congress and represent my hometown
in like 20 or 30 years and
the guy said run for congress
that's the best way to get prepared to
run for congress so you know what
we decided we're going to do this and so
we ran for congress in 1988
and we decided to run on the theme of
faith family and freedom
and so then you know we were young back
then and we said okay you know what
two years went by we're gonna do this
again
in 1990 and we're gonna run on faith
family and freedom
and we lost and so you know what we felt
like you know
maybe maybe this was our idea maybe this
wasn't god's calling on our life
and so we built our dream home we
started
our family mike started a radio show
that was all over the state of indiana i
started a watercolor business
and we were like very comfortable and
i'll just tell you
that's usually when god puts your life
in a blender
and that's what happened to us because
in 2000
we did feel a calling on our life to run
and mike said the scene i ran for is an
open seat
let's run let's run again and i said
okay
let's run and so we did and we ran on
the theme of
faith family and freedom
and we won
but over those 12 years that mike was in
congress from 2000 to 2012
unless there was a delay in the flights
we were together on sundays and we
worshiped together as a family
because mike would go back and forth to
indiana
all the time but on sundays we were
together as a family
and he stood for the principles of
freedom
in the united states congress he rose to
the third highest position
in the house of representatives and he
would leave
yeah that he would leave the hill and
he'd come to our son's lacrosse game
or he'd leave the hill and he'd go to
charlotte's violin lesson
or he'd leave the hill and go see audrey
in a little school play
or we would go to the hill and we'd take
him tacos and we'd sit on the steps of
the capitol and have tacos
so he made family a priority back then
[Applause]
[Music]
so in 2012 in 2012
we decided it's time to go home it's
time to go home to indiana
and mike ran for governor and he ran on
the theme of
faith family and freedom
and we won the governor of indiana and
so
four years later we were getting ready
to run for re-election
and when we were getting ready to run
for re-election
somebody called and had
another idea for us uh and after we
had the president melania and and had
they had time to figure out what they
wanted to do the president called
and this is what he said mike
it's gonna be great i know you can hear
him saying thank you
and mike said well if there's a question
there
the answer is yes and so
we ran again on the theme of faith
family and freedom
and for four years president donald
trump
has been fighting for your faith
your family and your freedoms
and somebody else has been standing
right next to him
ladies and gentlemen welcome the vice
president of the united states
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i'll hello you what it is great to
be with all of you today
congressman david schweicher
congresswoman david velasco
[Applause]
gene and jason back all the men
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a special joy to be here
with a marine corps law a champion of
military families
she even teaches art at a christian
school and you just heard
firsthand how blessed i am
to be married for these 35 years of the
wonderful carrots
here to be in arizona today we're here
for one reason
and one reason only and that is that
arizona
and america need four more years
[Applause]
we are 26 days away from another great
victory for the american people
and the road to victory runs right
through arizona
[Applause]
really it's great to be with holland
thank you for coming out in this
cool and breezy area
tell you what our family's getting a
little more familiar with arizona
because our son
captain michael j pence and his wife are
stationed at the marine corps base in
yuma arizona
karen and i just got back from a little
stop in salt lake city utah
some people think we did all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let me be clear folks it's a privilege
to be on that stage
i think last night's debate was not so
much a debate between two candidates for
vice president
it was a debate between two divisions
use taxpayer funding to pay for abortion
all the way up to the moment
you didn't figure it out watching last
night i'll tip you off they want to pack
the supreme court
and defund the police president donald
trump
we've rebuilt our military
[Applause]
[Music]
we unleashed american energy we secured
our border supported law enforcement and
we stood for life
and liberties every single day
[Music]
[Applause]
agenda with all that president trump has
done
these last three and a half years i
think there's no question about it
president donald trump won that
[Applause]
president donald trump
now four years ago a movement was born a
movement of everyday americans from
every walk of life here in arizona you
believe we could be
strong again we believe we could be
prosperous
you know i heard that joe biden had come
to harrison
both in arizona today
i got a feeling it's because arizona
said yes to president donald trump in
2016.
and i know arizona is going to say yes
to four more years
it's because of what we've done and what
we've accomplished together
four years ago we inherited a military
that was hollowed out by devastating
budget cuts
economies struggling to break free at
the slowest
economic recovery since the great
depression
terrorism was on the rise and we
witnessed a steady assault on our most
cherished values
but in just three short years we rebuilt
that military
we restored the arsenal of democracy and
we're finally giving our soldiers
sailors
airmen marines and coast guard the
resources and the support that they
deserved
[Applause]
[Music]
and i'm proud to report that president
donald trump to sign the largest
investments in our national defense
since the days of ronald reagan
[Applause]
so we've stood with those who served but
we've also stood with all of you who've
learned the uniform of the united states
you know when joe biden was vice
president america saw
years of scandal at the va that shocked
the conscience
of the nation we all remember those
things
some of the worst abuses happened not
far from here in phoenix at the va
veterans were literally dying while
waiting for the medical care that they
need
medical care that they earned in the
uniform of the united states
came into office that all changed we
passed the veterans accountability act
the most sweeping reforms of the va in
50 years
we fired thousands of va workers for not
giving our veterans the health care that
they
earn and veterans choice is now
available for every veteran
in america
[Music]
now i know this uh close to that air
force base is probably more than a few
of you that have served in uniform so if
you're able
would you mind standing up or raise your
hand and let us thank you one more time
[Applause]
thank you for your service god bless you
so it's been about security and about
supporting our veterans
in our first three years it was about
restarting the engine
of the american economy you know where
joe biden wants to raise taxes
in our first three years president
donald trump cut taxes across the board
for working families and businesses
we roll back more federal red tape than
any administration in history
we unleashed american energy bought for
free and fair trade
and in just three short years businesses
large and small created
seven million good-paying jobs
including more than 250 000 jobs
right here in arizona
and wages were rising across the board
but the most of the present to me is
waging for horizon most rapidly for hard
work and blue-collar parents
forgotten men and women of america were
forgotten no more
was vice president and i may have
brought this up last night
joe biden was vice president america
lost 200
000 manufacturing jobs and the last
president
actually said those jobs were never
coming back
remember four years ago he said and i
quote
what magic long do you have
well we didn't need a magic wand we just
needed president donald trump
[Music]
i mean you don't need to look any
further than right here at tier tactical
i just heard backstage from jason and
jane
it was because of president trump's tax
cuts
that they were actually able to expand
tier tactical
expand the facility we're standing in
right now
they're building another facility right
in front it's going to create
80 more good paid arizona
jobs can we give jason and jane a big
round of applause
so we stood for our national defense our
veterans
for jobs and every day of this
administration president donald trump
has stood for the rule of law we've
appointed
more than 200 principled conservatives
to our courts
at every level including two supreme
court justices and i will tell you
they are all men and women who will
uphold all the god-given liberties in
our constitution
i like the freedom of religion and the
second amendment
right to keep and bear arms
[Applause]
last month we paused as a nation
rightly honor the life and service of
the late justice ruth bader ginsburg
when the memorials were over president
donald trump fulfilled his
constitutional duty
and nominated a principle an experienced
brilliant conservative woman
to the supreme court of the united
[Applause]
states
i got to be honest with you i'm a big
fan of judge mary
and not just because she's from indiana
judge barrett is exactly the kind of
judge that president trump promised the
american people he would appoint
and then we've appointed all along the
way judges who will interpret the law as
britain who will not legislate from the
bench
who will uphold the constitution of the
united states that's why we need judge
andy cody barrett
to be justice amy coney
[Applause]
and i'll promise you after the senate
does their job of advising consent
we're going to fill that
[Applause]
so we stood for the rule of law
strengthen the constitutional
foundations
of our republic president donald trump
has stood every single day with the men
and women who serve on the thin blue
line of law enforcement
and we always will
[Applause]
president and i know what jason just
said
men and women who serve in law
enforcement across america are some of
the best people in this country
and they deserve the respect of every
american
every single day
now president trump and i will always
support the right of americans and
peaceful protests
rioting and looting is not peaceful
protest
burning businesses is not free speech
last night in salt lake city i had with
me a wonderful one
african-american business owner from
minneapolis
it's just a few days after the killing
of george floyd
let me say again there's no excuse for
what happened to george floyd
and justice will be served
[Applause]
in the days that followed flora
westbrook watched
as the protesters rioters and looters
moved closer and closer
to a business that she had built in the
largely african-american community 35
years ago
and they burned her to the ground
and women of arizona let me be clear
violence against innocent civilians the
destruction of private
property and violence against law
enforcement will not
be tolerated and those who
[Applause]
right while the american people
literally
watch businesses and their communities
burn in our major cities
now the truth is joe biden would double
down on the very policies that have led
to violence in america
when you when you suggest that you will
withdraw
support from those who protect and serve
you embolden those who would harm our
families
now joe biden justifies it by saying
that america
is in his word systemically racist
[Applause]
and he's actually said and kamala harris
repeated it last night
that police have an implicit bias
against minorities in this country
but joe biden was asked if he'd support
cutting funding for law enforcement
he replied yes absolutely
this running man has said that we need
to reimagine law enforcement and she
recently applauded
the mayor of los angeles efforts to cut
150
million dollars from la's budget
[Music]
well let me make you promise under
president donald trump
we're not going to defund the police
and here at this great company that
every single day not only employs people
all across this region but makes
equipment
for our heroes in law enforcement i'm
proud to report to you that under
president trump's leadership we're
providing more funding
for law enforcement more training and
more
resources and we're going to keep
supporting all
the enforcement
[Applause]
the president and i know we don't have
to choose between supporting law
enforcement and supporting our
african-american
families and other minorities in our
major cities
the truth is we've supported law
enforcement with all new resources
deployed personnel to cities struggling
with violence
and all along the way in this
administration we saw the lowest
unemployment ever recorded for african
americans
the highest investment in historically
black colleges and universities
this president was a champion of
educational
choice for all of our families and we
pass
prison justice reward
[Applause]
truth is we can we can support law
enforcement and support
more opportunities better education
better public safety in our
african-american communities in our
major cities
we have done both for the last three and
a half years
and we're going to continue to do both
for four more
years
[Applause]
it really is an honor to be here family
owned business that literally is saving
the lives men and women in law
enforcement
every day under this president's
leadership i've told it
they've created more than 120 new
arizona jobs
and every year this company makes some
20 000 protective vests
that are worn by law enforcement across
america
and american forces stationed all around
the world can you just give one more
round of
[Applause]
[Music]
all about applause in god and love
your country foreign
under president donald trump i promise
you've grabbed law and order in every
city in this country
for every american
so we rebuilt our military we revived
our economy we stood
for life for our liberties in law and
order
in just three short years
we made america great again and none of
those would have been possible with our
incredible
partners in congress would you join me
in thanking two of the most principled
conservatives in washington
dc people who have stood in the gap
and stood by this president every step
of the way
congressman david schweikert and
congresswoman
[Applause]
thank you for your incredible support
i'm just going to ask you right now we
need you to
we need you to return congressman dave
schweikert
congresswoman debbie lesko to a new
republican majority in the united states
[Applause]
we house of retire anti-policy
so we made incredible progress it was a
wonderful
three years under this president's
leadership promises made promises
and then the coronavis struck from china
but i'm here to report to you before the
first documented case of community
transmission
president trump's leadership shown
forward
before january was out our president did
what no american president
had ever done in the history of this
country he suspended all
travel from china the second largest
economy in the world
joe biden said that was xenophobic
hysterical he said it was fear-mongering
and wrote an essay
in usa today that said it would make
things worse
and i want to tell you as the head of
the white house corona myers test
president trump's actions suspending
travel from china
saved untold american lives that bought
us
time to stand up for the greatest
national mobilization since world war ii
we reinvented testing over 115 million
tests done so far
we saw the manufacturer delivery of
literally billions of medical supplies
to our amazing
doctors and nurses and health care
workers
we partnered with major research
companies in this country we develop
medicines that are literally saving
lives every day
and we are on track to have the first
safe and effective coronavirus
vaccine and tens of millions of doses
before the end of this year
[Applause]
let me say on behalf of president trump
how moved we
have all been the outpouring of concern
and prayers for the president and the
first lady
over this past week
i spoke to the president this morning
told him i was headed to arizona
and i got to tell you president trump
and first lady melania are doing just
great and he's going to be back on the
road
and in the fight before you know it
[Applause]
so the outpouring of concern for our
first family
the president and i know it's just
emblematic of the love
and care the wonderful medical treatment
that
every american family impacted by the
coronavirus
really is incredible so would you join
me
can we just say thank you to our doctors
our nurses
our first responders
[Music]
we keep protecting the baltimore but
we're going to keep saving lives
and we're going to keep opening up
america again
the truth is because of the strong
foundation this president
in those first three years because of
the unprecedented support
direct payments to families in a
paycheck protection
program that saved 50 million american
jobs the american economy is coming
back stronger than ever before
we lost 22 million jobs in the height of
this pandemic
because of the support we provided i
heard the tear tactical took advantage
of that paycheck protection program to
keep people unable
in the last five months alone we've
already seen
more than 11 and a half million
americans go back to work including 172
000 right here in the grand canyon
[Applause]
arizona's unemployment rate is already
cut
in half the arizona and american
comeback
is underway
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let me just say none of that would have
been possible
without the seamless partnership strong
and compassionate leadership of governor
doug ducey would you join me in thanking
[Applause]
governor
so we've gone through a time of testing
i came here today because in 26 days
coming to a time for choosing and the
choice in this election has never been
cleared
stakes have never been higher i can tell
you all know
joe biden is uh dubai
actually wants to raise taxes by four
trillion dollars in the midst of global
pandemic
president trump we not only cut taxes in
the last three and a half years
we're going to keep cutting middle class
taxes for four more years
president donald trump's already rolled
back more federal red tape and unleashed
the american economy as never before joe
biden and kamala harris
they want to pass a true trillion-dollar
version of the green
new deal and put us back in the paris
climate
[Music]
and stifle american jobs and
disadvantage american families
joe biden is for open borders sanctuary
cities
three lawyers in health care for illegal
immigrants
i think you here in arizona know what
all of that has been would mean
president donald trump we made record
investments in border security
mexico is doing more to secure our
border and theirs than ever before
and we've already built more than 300
miles
of that waterfall and with four more
years we're gonna build it all
[Applause]
when it comes to jobs and opportunity
you know i i know you all know about
that
where i come from out in the heartland
we literally saw entire
entire communities shuttered factories
closed
so long 60 000 factories were closed
and jobs shipped south of the border and
overseas
since 1995 when nafta became long
joe biden didn't lift a finger to reform
nafta president donald trump
renegotiated our trading relationship
with mexico and canada and the usmca
is here to stay it's a huge
and a huge win for america
finally joe biden and the democratic
party
support abortion on demand and support
using taxpayer dollars to pay for
abortion all the way up to the moment of
burden
i'll tell you i couldn't be more proud
to be vice president to a president who
stands without apology
for the sanctity of human life president
donald trump
[Music]
is
it's clear joe biden
the democratic party have been overtaken
by the radical level
joe biden will be nothing more than a
trojan horse
the extreme agenda of the radical left
now joe biden says that democracy is on
the ballot
on november 3rd
well i think our economic recovery is on
the ballot
i think law and order are on the battle
but i also think
there are things more foundational to
our country that are on the battle
you know i think in this election year
when it's all said and done it's not
going to be whether america is more
republican or more democrat
more liberal or more conservative
or greater i think the choice of this
election is whether america
remains america it's whether we're going
to let joe biden and kamala harris
steer our nation onto a course
of socialism and decline whether we are
going to keep
america on the path of freedom
free markets and all the ideals that
have made this country great
that's been our choice
that's why we need to decide right here
and right now
that joe biden will never be president
of the united states
we're going to re-elect president donald
trump for four
more years
[Applause]
four more years needs more jobs
four more years means more judges four
more years means more support for our
troops
and it's going to take at least four
more years to drain that swap
men and women i've been serving
alongside this president
every day for the last three and a half
years i've known it just a little bit
longer than that
some people think we're a little bit
different
i'll be honest with you we've become
very close friends
i've seen him up close the cameras are
off
but nobody's looking
and hand to my heart i can tell you
there's never been a day gone by that
president donald trump hasn't gone up
and
fought to keep the promises that he made
the people
of arizona now it's our turn to fight
for him
it's on arizona
you need to bring all this enthusiasm
keep voicing your support talk to your
neighbors and friends and worship and
work all across the grand canyon state
say i ran into mike over in peoria
and he talked for like 40 minutes out in
the hot blazing sun
and just talked about what we've just
begun to do for the americans
that's right and how this president has
led our nation to one of the greatest
challenging years in my lifetime
i mean go and tell the story and when
you do i want you to have faith
have faith in the people of this country
and the truth is good word i think a
careful study of american history shows
that
every time the american people have been
given a choice between more freedom
and less freedom they choose a future of
more freedom every single time
so talk to your neighbors and friends
just like they did before in 2016.
we're going to choose american greatness
again
and if you're inclined knee from time uh
time
i'd encourage you to exercise that other
kind of faith too
jason was talking about talking about
that from this podium he was
talking about it with us backstage you
know you turn on the television these
days and it's kind of like that little
girl asked me a question in the debate
last night
it seemed like on tv it looks like
there's more that divides us in this
country that
unites us i got to tell you i've
traveled all across america the last
four years and i can tell you
there will always be more that unites
the people of the united states of
america
than will ever divide us the chief among
those things is
a nation of faith
so in the next 26 days i'd encourage you
to
encourage you to pray for america yeah
pray for all
the american people when you pray pray
with confidence
if his people who are called by his name
will humble himself
and pray that he'll do like he's always
done
in the long story history of this great
nation
he'll hear from heaven and he'll heal
this land
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
[Music]
i just know with your continued support
the energy that i see out here in the
arizona sun today
every day between now and november 3rd
i'm going to make arizona and america
stronger than ever before
yeah we make arizona and america
safer than ever before congressman david
schweigert and congresswoman debbie
lesko and a new republican majority
in the house of representatives and with
president donald trump in the white
house
for four more years and with costco
we're going to make america great again
[Applause]
again
[Music]